[Music]
I shot a ton of CEOs 12 covers the snake
thing has got to be the craziest origin
story I've ever heard honestly it was
boring compared to what came next
we started off in coastal Florida we got
driving here we're prepared to purchase
our entire crop what do you say
[Music]
[Applause]
Jillian back desk now
we're in business no vaccies
second my business got even a tiny bit
of success people showed up trying to
take it I want to talk to you about a
proposition
happens about saying no
come on what the hell did you feed the
gator well the thing about Buttercup
they'll name him and definitely not
buttercup
s
This creepy Swamp family they screwed me
over we split the profits 80 20. Vanessa
and Camille are counting on me my
brother keep it above board who are you
I'm with the state of Florida we're
shutting you down don't worry guys
you'll keep getting paid and Margarita
Monday is still on you can't promise
them that I already Juiced the lives
Craig
this is my farm the I own shut up
like I promise as a plan it won't be
pretty let's go suit up Dolores
Laura you have to wear underwear in the
common areas the bathroom is a common
area and I'm naked
look at this we are building a business
here no crimes no scams it's time we
escalate this situation sometimes in
business people get hurt
what was that wow that was crazy do you
think I might be repressing some anger
you guys Jillian I do think so
you can say what you want
foreign